[APPLAUSE]
Oh my word!
And suddenly the aircraft's
depressurising!
You've got to get these oxygen
masks on as quick as you
possibly can!
One!
Perfect.
In you go, fast as you can!
My name's Hugh Montgomery.
I'm Professor of Intensive
Care Medicine at UCL in
London, University College
London, where I direct the
Institute for Human Health
and Performance.
My lectures were in 2007 on the
science of survival with
the running title of Back
From The Brink.
When a meteorite struck the
Earth, it produced massive
climate change.
And that climate change was
not something that the
dinosaurs could adapt
to, and they died.
But your ancestors survived.
And in fact, they were lucky.
But you're very lucky, too,
because there have been five
or six episodes of mass
extinction in the Earth's
history, all caused by climate
change, and every single time,
your ancestors have survived.
In every case, we manage to hang
the lecture around a real
life survivor.
So that for me was the most
exciting part of it.
We had some tremendous
people in.
Mike Stroud, who had man-hauled
across Antarctica.
Ranulph Fiennes.
And from that slot up there,
right in the ceiling,
abseiling in, Jamie Andrew,
who'd been stuck on a mountain
in the Alps for nearly seven
days, and ended up having both
arms and legs amputated.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, there's an entrance,
Jamie.
Thank you very much
for joining this.
Now, this was an extraordinary
feat of survival.
I think people looking at that
mountain, though, might not
have quite a feel for
how cold it was.
How cold were you
on that ridge?
It was very cold, indeed.
I mean, the temperatures were
measured at minus 30 degrees
C.
And strong winds as well?
130 kilometres an hour down
in the valley that day.
I think the demonstrations are
crucial to the Christmas
Lectures, partly because
that's what they've
always had in them.
It's like trying to
have Christmas
without turkeys and pudding.
You just can't do it as
a Christmas Lecture.
And CGI and so forth will never
replace that real sense
of awe children get when they
see something happening in
front of them which
can also go wrong.
And they're working on
quite low pressure.
And what I'd like you to do,
without stabbing and putting
your finger through, is
give that a push for
me when it's inflated.
What does it feel like?
Squidgy.
Squidgy!
There we go.
Isn't that beautiful?
And it's a lovely looking
heart, that.
Put a twist in it.
The molecule just
twists around.
And as you can see, if I only
kept doing that, you get the
famous double helix of DNA,
which you can see over here.
In terms of things going wrong,
I suppose that's also
rather a tradition of the
Christmas Lectures, and
actually makes it all
the more fun.
Because they're not
edited out, these
things that go wrong.
When things don't work, that's
part of the narrative.
And we had model just over to my
right, actually, from where
I'm sitting now, of a cutout
man with a column that was
meant to give an index of how
much water he had in them.
And we got a child pouring
in water to the level
that he'd been at.
But of course, as often in the
Christmas Lectures, we were
down to the wire, Andy had been
working all night again
to try to get things together.
Everyone rushed to
get out there.
Off we go.
The child is on the stairs.
He's pouring the water in, and
it just poured straight out
the bottom, all over
the floor.
To here, now.
Oh, it's leaking!
We'd better stop, hadn't we?
He's having a pee!
[LAUGHTER]
Your dad can't hold
his beer, can he?
Right!
[LAUGHTER]
Better get you out of the way.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
Presenting to children is every
bit as demanding as
presenting to adults,
if not more so.
And I was trained by a professor
many years ago
called Eric Neal, who was
one of the world's great
physiologists.
And I remember him saying to
me when I was merely a BSE
student, he said to me, Hugh,
if you can't explain your
science to a five-year-old, it
means you don't understand it.
So genes are very important
because at the beginning of
each of them, there's a little
accelerator region.
Just imagine it's a few
of these letters.
And if you switch on that
accelerator, you
switch on the gene.
You switch on the gene, you
make more of the protein.
So a gene determines which
protein you make, in what
cell, how much, and when.
So I suppose all in all, the
Royal Institution Lectures are
hugely stressful.
Very time consuming.
But an enormous honour,
tremendously good fun, and the
reward of hearing 300 children
for five nights in a row
hanging on your every
word is fantastic.
I strongly commend it for others
to do in the future.